my name is Professor George Paul Reiser
I am professor of leadership and
organizational behavior at IMD in
Lausanne Switzerland the idea behind the
hostage at the table concept is that
when we are held hostage with a gun it's
obvious we are physical hostage and
there are people who can talk interact
even when they're held physically
hostage and as a result get themselves
free or hostage negotiators can do that
then the idea is that you can be a
hostage even without a gun to your head
and there are many people who do not
really feel freedom of choice they do
not really feel that they can do what
they want or influence what they want
this is particularly important for
leaders because leaders without a gun to
their head can feel like or be in a
state where they are acting as if they
have a gun to their head and they are
not it can be to a colleague it can be
to a boss it can be to a client a
customer it can also be to themselves so
the idea is that how do we help leaders
really free up their potential be able
to truly make choices influence and
persuade and do this without the
negative states that go with being a
psychological hostage
but the way is to really understand that
you always have choice so that if you
are in a situation where you are
pressured where you feel trapped what
you have to stop and do is go back
inside and connect with how you feel
what it is that you want and that's why
the first basic tool the first pillar of
leadership is around focus how do I
focus my mind's eye now we have to
understand that the mind's eye part of
your brain is fundamentally determined
if you're looking for positive you're
looking for negative if you are looking
for the problems or you're looking for
the solutions the other part of this
focus is that you have to take control
of it because your brain is naturally
going to be looking for danger looking
for pain looking for what's wrong so
that to not be a hostage to be an
impactful high-performing leader you
must do in your brain in your mind
focusing on where you want to go what's
interesting is that 80% of people do not
do that 80% of people are in fact
looking for the danger that's how the
brain is hardwired and only about 20% on
average are looking for where there is
possibilities where there are
opportunities great leaders
high-performing leaders do not allow
themselves to be a hostage to looking
for those negatives and so you can have
a leader who builds a team or builds a
whole organization around people who
truly are playing to win and playing to
win means I do not allow myself to be a
hostage to my fears and to the avoidance
of risk taking risks calculation is
important but to be able to focus on
where you want to go and then bring
people with you that's one of the true
characteristics of a high